let's move forward now last time we were
solving trigonometric equations but we
focused exclusively on sign ok that was
just so that good morning we nailed this
idea but now let's extend it a little
bit so you can see I had my cosine graph
here i'm going to use this it doesn't
have to be beautiful it just has to be
close enough so that i can see what's
going on to solve this equation here now
you remember the big I concept and skill
that I was trying to get across last
time is it whenever you see solve and
then there's something left something on
the right ok each of these really
represents a graph it represents a graph
so when I gave you this before x squared
plus 5x plus 6 equals 4 for instance x
squared plus 5x plus 6 is a graph it's a
parabola right like that ok and for is
also a graph it's a straight line
horizontally and I'm looking for where
these two collide ok so cos x there's my
cos x crap right what else should I put
on here if I've got this on the
right-hand side that's one right so I've
got a half there so right through the
equation through the graph I'm going to
draw in a half ok that's half and by a
graph I'll kill your vision one is cos x
so if I want cos x equals a half that's
where cos x equals a hug and you can see
I've got two points of intersection
right 12 ok so at this point you can see
if we want the first solution just like
we did here and here it's that a sine
inverse of course so I should go cos
inverse right so shift cause if you pop
in a half ok it should give you a
solution which I hope you can start to
recognize by now what's the exact value
for cause that gives you a half it's 60
degrees isn't it okay 60 degrees just
pause for a second does that make sense
let's have a look at our cosine graph
haven't finished off yet it's gone from
north to 360 but I haven't laid with all
these important points it freezes what
are these two guys
you actually know what one of them is it
cos ninety that's right it's equal to 0
what's the other one have a look what
would you guess it looks like now I've
gone all a 360 here so halfway ought to
be 180 so that's where it sort of dips
down it has its valley right which means
the next one over will be 270 270 okay
now i have a sense of the scale of this
thing does 60 degrees make sense does it
look that right i think so like week
this that's the way i would expect to be
answer i draw a dotted line down that's
about 60 I mean you know it was a rough
graph I just got through my mind but
it's in the right ballpark okay so there
is 60 degrees that's solution one okay
but I have another solution now remember
all these trigger two graphs they're
like symmetrical like crazy okay the
symmetry everywhere in fact this shape
that I've got right now if i divide it
right down the middle it's just a
reflection right it's just a reflection
so if i went forward 60 degrees to get
this solution how am I going to get the
other one I want to go backwards from
360 right can you see that that just is
there should exactly match this distance
here do you see that okay so if it's
also 60 degrees that distance and I'm
starting from 360 going backwards what's
the actual example maybe 300 right and
of course if we're correct you can grab
your calculator and you can put it in
cause 300 and supplies surprise you get
1 over 2 so here is my second answer and
I can see from my graph I haven't missed
any 12 points of insertion that's it